what so proudly we
sailed if you've ever tried to sing the
star-spangled banner
you see you know it's not easy
[Music]
can't go that high the lowest note and
the highest note are an
octave and a half apart that's 12 full
notes for comparison god save the queen
spans
seven notes oh canada it's nine
yes exactly estelle this is why we need
a new national anthem
what no just this is exactly why the
national anthem
is so great no no no no the french
anthem that's great
and it's got a range of nine notes nine
notes is enough to make
yvonne cry in casablanca
that just feels like failure i know the
words to it but i'm so aware of how bad
i sound i'm like
i have to stop right now
[Music]
and it's not just the overall range the
whole song feels like it's trying to
lose us
starting with the first line if you go
oh say
can you see i've already traversed an
octave from say to c
that's music theory expert paula telesco
so now i've traversed a tenth and we're
only in the second measure
and then right here you're also hit with
a chromatic note
which means it's not in the same key
that the rest of the notes are in
and that comes right after this dive
an interval is the distance between two
notes if they're right next to each
other they're called steps
most music moves by step meaning a much
smaller percentage of
skips but the star-spangled banner is
full of skips including fourths fifths
sixths a tenth so you know it's kind of
treacherous
that's why music teachers in the 30s
opposed the law that officially made the
star-spangled banner our national anthem
and a writer in the 1920s said that no
one with a normal esophagus can sing it
without
screaming and in 1906 the washington
post called it perhaps the most
unlovely tune that was ever wrung from
the quivering bowels of a horn
are you done yes i'm just saying
shouldn't the national anthem be
something we can all sing exactly okay
but how often do you
really need to do that i mean consider
the context where most americans even
hear this song
the super bowl nba finals the world
series
why shouldn't the national anthem
performance be just as challenging
and anxiety written as whatever sporting
event it's commencing
what happens when you start too high
you're screwed you're totally screwed
that's matt farnsworth he's a vocal
coach and teacher in new york city
people think i should just start in a
comfortable range like
oh jose that would be my comfortable
range but really i need to start down
here
otherwise i'm going to be very very high
by the time i get to the end of the song
and the vowels in these lyrics make it
even harder for the let open vowel end
of the
and then all of a sudden you have to go
to a closed vowel which is e
e and you are closed vowels free so
you've got to figure out how to sing
the eve out with an open throat but
closing on top
talented singers pull this off by mixing
their chest and head voice
so chest voice is like your ethyl
mermaid get by right guys too broadway
right head voice is when we think of
like opera singers
if you're just using your chest voice at
the land of the free
it'll sound like this
and then you feel that fri it just feels
like it's not gonna go
but if you incorporate your head voice
just a little
it's like hitting a game-winning
fadeaway jump shot
[Music]
and notice how jennifer hudson went up
even more on free
that's not just an octave and a half
that's two
octaves there's one person who did it so
well that a recording of the song
peaked at 20 on the billboard hot 100.
[Applause]
if our anthem was easy to sing joss we
would not get these moments
[Applause]
okay i'm not saying that i don't have
goosebumps but let the record show that
that microphone was not
on wait wait wait wait wait that was
pre-recorded
you're killing my heart right now are
you positive but let's talk about the
lyrics which were written by a slave
holder and in the third stanza they
celebrate the death of slaves
who sided with the british in the war of
1812.
but the song is about fort mchenry in
baltimore which withstood a 24-hour
attack from the british navy so the big
inspiring idea here
is that the country still exists
is it the ramparts yet i keep going to
the rampart
oh who's bright stripes hairless
knight um brave
these words are more descriptive than
motivating they're also phrased really
awkwardly so it's no wonder that they
just don't stick
[Music]
you know i have a really good laugh
about it and you know you get over
things and
you know you you get back up again
christina you deserve better
no no no hold up america loves watching
people publicly fail
written by francis scott off-key we
should be
grateful that the star-spangled banner
gives us those moments
yeah i don't know quite what it was that
i was watching
but i think that's another example of i
think she really tried to do something
new with it
and it just wasn't as successful as she
hoped it would be yes
it's risky for performers to try
something new
but when they do it well it's amazing
let's rewind back to 1968.
it's game 5 of the world series and jose
feliciano a 23 year old blind puerto
rican folk singer
is there to do the anthem
[Music]
now it's immediately apparent this
doesn't sound like the star-spangled
banner
it's the height of the vietnam war and
our national anthem
sounds like a peaceful folk tune
finishes it and then listen closely
[Music]
there are booze
one woman was so angry she said she was
gonna write a letter to her senator to
complain
but rca released the live recording as a
single
and it was the first time the national
anthem made it on the billboard charts
fifteen years later marvin gaye walked
up to center court at the 1983 nba
all-star game
with a shocking amount of swagger and
took a cue from feliciano
[Music]
by the end the crowd was clapping with
him
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't need a different national
anthem to feel something
we just need the right singer like maybe
these singers
[Music]
so you want one of those to be our
national anthem to be honest they're a
little religious for my taste
see people have tried in vain to replace
the star spangled banner for
a really long time it's not going
anywhere
anytime soon so just enjoy it when it's
good
and enjoy it when it's bad too
[Applause]
[Music]
we watched so gallantly streaming